Thank you for coming to AIM 383.
Build more effective agent through model customization.
I'm gonna be one of the two hosts, David De Galitelli,
worldwide senior specialist solutions architect for
the StageMaker AI team.
I have the pleasure to have with me on stage today, Sam.
Sam, you wanna introduce yourself? Hey everyone, my name is
Sam Palani, and I lead the Nova
go to market team here at EWS.
Awesome, thank you very much. This is a silent
session, so you guys are happy to
come ask questions after the session.
We're pretty packed on content, so there's a lot
to go through.
Without further, you know, waiting, we're just gonna
go ahead and get started.
The agenda, as I was saying, is pretty packed.
There's a lot to talk about, uh, lots of
new things coming.
A lot of new things were announced as of
yesterday and Tuesday. Hope you guys checked out the
keynotes. Today we're gonna go through
how to build custom AI agents using
the Amazon Nova Foundation models.
How many Foundation models do we have available
when we talk about the Amazon Nova family?
And then because we know that you guys have your own
kind of use cases and you have your own peculiarities
in the way that you solve your tasks, we will
show you how to customize Amazon
Nova models. There's different techniques,
uh, both from a point of view of the
open source community as well as the specifics
of what we allow you to do
within Bedrock and Sagemaker. So we're gonna go
through that.
Of course, this is not an AWS tech talk.
It doesn't come with a demo,
so we're gonna go through an example of a model
customization using
Amazon Sage Maker as part of a demo.
And then finally we'll wrap up. We'll give you some
resources to get started and to learn
more about how to use Nova for your
use cases.
All right? With that said,
not gonna take any more of your time. I'm gonna let
Sam do the rest of the talk. Thank you. Thanks,
David. So
how many of you have attended a silence session
before? OK.
For those who have not, I'm with you because
this is also my first silence session.
So let's see how this goes.
Let's start with the basics. What is an AI
agent? Now
there are quite a few definitions of what
an AI agent is,
but a simple one that most of the
industry is also gravitating towards is
to think of them as
LLMs calling tools in a loop to
accomplish a goal.
Let's break that down a bit.
So an agent has access to a model.
A set of tools and is given
a very specific goal.
It then uses these tools to take
certain actions within an environment.
The environment can be something like your
web browser, your computer terminal,
or even your enterprise application. It then
analyses the results of these actions
to verify if the goal has been met.
If the goal is met,
the loop ends. If not, the
agent continues to take more actions
until the goal is accomplished.
So there you have it, a model calling
tools in a loop to accomplish a goal.
But let's also look at what's causing this inflection
point in agentic AI, starting with reasoning
models. Now
sometime last year there was a perception
that frontier model intelligence had hit a
wall. It seemed that
we had consumed all the data that was available
to train these models, and most model
releases seemed more like incremental
updates rather than a fundamental
shift in frontier intelligence.
It also seemed that the scaling laws were
no longer working.
Just a quick recap, the scaling laws famously
stated that if you
add more data,
continue to train longer, keep
increasing the model size, you will eventually
get a more
performance model.
It seemed that that was no longer holding true.
All this changed when reasoning models
burst into the scene. Suddenly the focus
shifted from pure training
to test time compute and inference time
compute. What happened was that
these new models were able to think and
act out of the box, unlocking new capabilities
for agentic AI that was
previously challenging.
The other benefit of reasoning
models was that it enabled you to
deploy agents at scale and
in a cost effective manner.
For example, you could now break down
complex long running tasks into smaller
tasks and run them in parallel at
scale. You could also
choose to route tasks based on complexity
to a smaller and more efficient variant
of the model, making it more cost effective.
Now a model with all the intelligence
and reasoning capabilities can only
do so much if it doesn't have
access to your specific context.
So what we saw was during this time,
organizations also invested in building a secure
data infrastructure
that enabled them to connect their proprietary
data to these powerful models.
And last but not the least, the emergence of
specialized tooling
and technologies such as model
context protocol, the agent to agent protocol,
model level skills, and even tool calling
further streamline the process of building and
deploying these agents.
But this is not just us.
This is what customers like you and builders
like you are telling us.
According to Gartner, 1/3 of all
enterprise applications would be powered
by generative AI or agentic AI
by 2028.
And 15% of all day to day
business decisions would be taken autonomously
by an AI agent.
To put these things in perspective,
at the same time last year, this number was close
to 1%.
They also predict that of all these AI
interactions, at least 1/3
of them would involve invoking an action
model
or an AI agent for task completion.
But this is not a road map of the future. This is happening
right now.
Although this session is around customization,
it's also important to understand that customization
is just one step in your journey to production,
where you have other steps such as building, deployment,
and testing.
For now though, we'll focus on customization.
But why talk about customization
in the context or model customization in
the context of agents?
Now while Frontier model intelligence has
increased, it also exhibits
brittle behavior, specifically with agentic
AI. You saw that
an agent takes a series of steps
to accomplish a goal.
This introduces a unique risk that
we sometimes call it as compounding
mistakes, where an error from one
step propagates and compounds to the
other step.
For instance,
consider a scenario where your model achieves
95% accuracy on a single
step. Over the course of 10
steps, there is a risk that this might actually
reduce to around 60%, turning a
highly performing model into a very unreliable
agent. Now customization
can directly help reduce these errors,
both at the step level as well as across
the steps.
The next one is not specific to agentic AI
but still very applicable here. Your
domain specific acronyms, taxonomies,
and business process knowledge are
not internet average.
Customization can help align and steer
the model to your specific business semantics.
We also talked about tools in the context of agents.
In order for these models to make these
tool calls perfectly in the first
attempts, it's important that they have a
good understanding of the underlying
schema as well as the parameters
needed to invoke these tools.
Customization can directly help you do that.
Now related to the problem of compounding
mistakes, customization can
help compress long running chains
within your agentic workflow.
Your model learns micro policies
for each step. You get shorter trajectories,
fewer backtracks, and fewer dead ends.
Customization techniques such as distillation
can directly help reduce your
P50 and P90 latency
and cost per step.
But what do we mean by customization?
Again, a bare bones definition that
I'd like to think about here is
customization is anything that
you do to a model to modify its behavior.
It has a broad set of options as you can
see here, ranging from simple and progressing
in complexity.
At a high level, we like to break this down into
two categories, which is optimizing the output
and modifying the underlying model itself.
Or in other words,
optimizing the output, no weight updates,
and modifying the model where you actually make
weight updates to the model.
At the very simplest end of the
spectrum, you have techniques such as prompt
engineering, which is a bucket term that we use
to describe everything ranging from
simple, few short examples to more
complex chain of thought examples to everything in
between, such as crafting efficient
systems and user prompts.
Next we have retrieval augmented generation or
RAG. While context
sizes of these models have
increased exponentially in the past few years,
RA continues to be a very effective
way of providing additional
context to the models, especially at runtime.
context engineering has emerged as
the most effective way of optimizing
the model specifically for agentic AI.
Now sticking to our theme of keeping things
simple, we can consider context
engineering as providing the right
information in the right format and at the right
time to the model.
Now if you think about it, a model needs more than just
the prompts.
It also needs to have a good understanding
of the tools that it has access to,
any additional context that was retrieved
as part of the rack pipeline,
as well as a memory of all
previous interactions.
Now in contrast to prompt engineering, which
involves working with discrete prompts,
context engineering is an iterative
process where the curation happens
each time a pass to an LLM is made.
Now moving on to the techniques which involve
modifying the underlying model itself,
we can break this down further into two
subcategories, post-training techniques and
pre-training techniques.
This is also where we'll spend the rest of this breakout
session on.
On the post-training side, you have techniques
such as fine-tuning or supervised fine tuning,
model distillation, and reinforcement
learning techniques such as direct preference
optimization, DPO
and PPO.
And on the post-training side, we have techniques
such as continued pre-training.
And we'll go into each of these techniques in
much more detail as we progress along.
Starting with fine tuning.
Now, just by a show of hands, how many of you
have tried fine tuning?
OK. Good.
So when we talk about fine
tuning,
this includes both full fine tuning,
which involves modifying the base model
weights, as well as performance
efficient fine tuning or theft,
where you freeze the base layers and train
only a set of added low rank
parameters, also known as adapters.
They're called low rank because they are of a lower dimension
or rank compared to the weights of the base
model. You
start by adapting a model
to a specific task by using a relatively
small labeled data set.
As such, this is also referred to as supervised
fine tuning.
We use direct preference optimization
or DPO when you want to align
the model to a very specific user preference
without having to train a reward model.
You can do DPO either in a performance
efficient way, as we discussed above, or
you could do a full DPO.
Proximal policy optimization, or
PPO is a way to improve
your model based on live feedback.
How do you get that live feedback? You can
get that via a task completion,
a tool execution, or more commonly,
via direct human feedback.
A few important things to remember here is that
you will need a full cycle of reinforcement
learning here and as such you will need a reward
model and a function.
This is also more costly and time
consuming,
but can give you really good results for
very specific use cases.
Model distillation is a technique where you distill
complex behaviors from a larger
and a high performing model known
as the teacher model
to a smaller and a more efficient model
that we refer to as a student model.
As we saw earlier,
distillation can directly help reduce
your latency and cost at a task level.
Continuous pre-training, as the name implies, is
a pre-training technique where you continue
to train on the pre-training
checkpoints of the base model
using a large corpus of unlabeled
data. Now
again, important points over here is that you
will need a large corpus of unlabeled
domain-specific data.
You should also
watch out for risks such as overfitting
and catastrophic forgetting.
There are additional techniques that you can do
such as early stopping
or implementing intelligent
data mixing to mitigate some of these risks.
And David will cover a lot about this
as he goes into the Sagemaker customization.
Now, uh, moving on to Amazon Nova.
So,
how many of you have used Nova over here?
Quite a few.
So we, we had a big release
just a couple of days back. This, this slide is
not updated to cover all of those releases, but I
will happily talk through all of them.
So at the very top, we have our understanding
and reasoning models, starting with Nova Micro,
which is our fastest and most efficient text
to text model.
Uh, we see a lot of customers use
micro in their latency sensitive
agentic work uh workflows.
Next we have our
multi-modal understanding and reasoning models
Light, Premiere and Pro, Light
Pro and Premiere,
each increasing in intelligence, with Premiere
being our most performant model
until 2 days back, because 2 days back
we released Nova 2 Pro,
which is now the most performant
model that is available.
A lot of customers use Premiere, used
to use Premiere in the past as the teacher
model within the distillation pipelines.
Now they'll probably use pro.
Next, we have our creative content generation
model, uh, starting with Nova
Canvas, which is our text to image
generation model,
and Nova Reels, which is our text to video
generation model.
2 days back we also announced Nova
2 Omni, which is the state of the art
and more performance text to image
generation model.
Next we have Amazon Nova Sonic, which is the
industry's first real-time speech to
speech model delivering frontier capabilities
such as automatic speaker recognition,
speaker dialization, polyglot voices,
as well as multilingual support.
Nova Act became generally
available 2 days back as well,
and it is an agentic browser
use model specifically designed
to build agents that operate within your browser.
We talked about agents taking actions in an
environment and one of those actions could be a web
browser. So if you are building an agent
that's designed to operate within
a web browser, then NA Act is a model
specifically designed to do that.
Now we all know that embeddings
are the foundation of any generative
AI application or an agentic AI
application. Very recently,
in fact, a couple of months back, we released the Nova
multimodal embeddings model,
which is the only embeddings model that is
available in the industry that will
generate embeddings for all your multimodal
data, which is
text, video, images, and audio
within the same vector space.
Why this is important is that this enables
you to build really powerful
applications that utilize semantic
search and agentic rag.
Last but not the least, we have our Nova public
website, nova.amazon.com,
where you can try out any of these models
free of charge or without needing
an AWS account.
Now the chart here looks busy,
but if you look at this, Nova provides
a broad range of customization
options both on Amazon Bedrock as
well as Sagemaker AI.
Most of these options are available both as
full rank options as well as
performance efficient low rank options that we
discussed above.
Depending on the option you choose, you can choose
to do your customization either on
Bedrock or you can do the customization
on Sagemaker AI.
Once you are done, you can deploy
this model in a Cerberus manner
on Amazon Bedrock. For example, if
you choose to do model distillation,
you can choose to do that very quickly
on Amazon Bedrock
or build your own distillation pipeline
on Sagemaker AI.
Once done, you can import your distilled
model onto Amazon Bedrock
and deploy it using on-demand inference
or provision throughput.
And we'll talk much more about these
deployment options as we progress further.
But for now,
let's look at specifically the Nova customization
options available on Amazon Bedrock,
starting with fine tuning.
Now we talked about fine tuning. We also covered
full fine tuning where you modify the
weights of the base model as well as performance efficient
fine tuning where you
train a set of added low rank parameters.
On Bedrock, you can do performance efficient
fine tuning and deploy your model
in just a few clicks.
Since this is a form of supervised
fine tuning, you start by uploading a
set of labeled data and kickstart
your fine tuning job.
Once your job completes,
the model is available on the Bedrock
platform just as any other Bedrock model
for evaluation and testing.
You could also try out the model
on the Bedrock model playground before
you decide to scale or deploy them.
One common use case agentic
AI use case that we see for
this type of fine tuning is for tool
calling and schema stickiness, where
you want the model to emit a very
specific Jason schema consistently.
Another good example over here is
for persona switching, where you want to use
the same base model across your agentic
AI workflow and have it switch
between multiple personas such as sales and
support. Now
as a quick recap, model distillation is a technique
where you distill complex behavior from a
larger and a highly performant model
to a smaller and more efficient model.
Now, have you, how many of you have
done model distillation here?
Very cool. We have one gentleman over there.
So if you have done model distillation, one
of the biggest challenges with model distillation
is building a robust data pipeline
for your distillation.
With Bedrock, you can do model distillation
again in just a few clicks.
Now if you think about it, distillation is just a
type of fine tuning with a teacher model in the loop.
What I mean by that is when you do this on Bedrock,
you start by picking your teacher model
and your student model.
You upload a set of task
specific prompts, just the prompts, not
the responses.
Bedrock will automatically use the teacher model
to generate the responses for your
prompts that you uploaded.
It will then use the prompts
and the responses generated by the
teacher model to fine tune the student
model. A
good example over here is productionizing
a high performing prototype.
For example, if your prototype
only works with a high performing model,
you can choose to distill those specific
behaviors into a smaller variant of the
model as you deploy and scale
it in your production.
Now talking about deployment, Bedrock offers
two modes of deployment on-demand inference,
which is token-based pay as you go pricing,
as well as provision throughput, where you pay
a fixed price upfront for guaranteed
throughput. With
that, we'll move over to the sage maker side of
customization, which David will
happily take us through.
Thank you, Sam.
Awesome.
I don't know if you guys saw the mind map
before about the different techniques of customizing
uh uh Nova. I just wanna call out that
it's a work that Sam did.
Uh, I think it's one of the best mind maps that I've seen in AWS
in the last 7 years that I've been in this
company, so I really wanna do a shout out to the
work that he has done
and to the work that he will do now that he goes back
because we have released new techniques now.
So you know that the first thing Monday is gonna do
when he comes back, it will be to update that that
slide. Awesome.
But let's focus now for a second on other
customization techniques. So you've seen
how to perform customization using Amazon
Bedrock so far
with the theft and with the model distillation
capabilities,
but let's go a little bit deeper, right?
So if you're a little bit more advanced
and you wanna have a little bit more control
on the fine tuning process,
Bedrock is still gonna give you a lot of bells and whistles
and a lot of knobs to turns.
However, if you wanna have a lower level
understanding and a lower level impact on
the training process,
SageMaker must be your go to tool.
It's an end to end machine learning platform, machine
learning engine AI platform, of course,
which allows you to choose a model that
you want to fine tune.
Perform fine tuning using the option
you prefer, and we have two examples
here, the training jobs API
for fully managed and
server-less
model fine-tuning. We have announced the serverless fine-tuning
just yesterday morning, so I really
suggest you guys check that out.
Or you can have a complete
orchestration managed by yourself,
yourself truly
in the form of Sagemaker Hyperpod.
Hyperpod is a managed cluster based
either on EKS or on SLUM
and allows you to really go
low, a level deeper, managing
the infrastructure
for your training workloads.
It allows you to really customize what kind of orchestration
you wanna do, as I was saying, through Slur Marques.
It allows you to also schedule the workloads
to make sure that you get the best of the
resources that you're actually paying for.
But not just that, SageMaker also provides
optimized recipes for you to
make sure that your training is
successful
and works well the first time.
So, what you've gotta focus on is not
figuring out what is the best code that you need to write
for your training loop.
Most of the time we see customers focusing on
the data science process, generating
the data if they don't have it,
cleaning their data if they already have
that. And then provide this data
to already well-known scripts.
So what we have done
in the back end is that we have taken those
scripts, we have customized some of those scripts,
making sure that they perform the best in
our architecture, and we have packaged
them in the form of recipes.
Now we call them hyperpod recipes, but they're
also working foragemer
training jobs.
So if you prefer a more serverless or managed
approach to training your model, absolutely
go ahead and use the SageMaker training job,
or SMTJ.
Or otherwise, if you want to have a lower level
of customization and orchestration,
those are also compatible for Hyperpod.
So, let's take a deeper look at how those
rep recipes work.
So, first of all, you're gonna go ahead and select your
Nova recipe.
You're gonna go ahead and make an API call to
Sage Maker control plane,
which will then leverage some of the launchers that
we have available in SageMaker,
spin up the right training job on the Hyperpod
instance, download the ECR
training image directly on those
instances that have been deployed.
And then finally, load the data
from the different data sources that you have. Whether
they are S3, whether they are FSX,
whether they are uh
EFS.
I know the image is a little bit fast,
and uh this is an image that I took from one of the blogs
that is publicly available. So if you guys wanna
learn more about how Sage Maker recipes
help you understand and how to help
simplify
training a model using SageMaker, you might
wanna scan the QR code that you see here on the right,
which will actually take you directly to the
blog post introducing this
uh this infrastructure.
I see a lot of people are taking pictures, so I'm gonna wait a
second until the full image is there,
and you guys gotta be fast.
There you go, now is the moment for the photo.
Perfect. All right.
Those lights will be sent offline anyway, so
don't worry if you can't really be as fast
as possible in taking that picture. It's
all available online. Once again, the blog
is gonna be your best friend.
So what I'm going to do now instead is gonna walk you
through a quick demo of how to
perform all of what I showed you in the architecture
before, actually do it in the studio console.
So one heads up I want to give you before I start
the demo is that as you know, we
have released a lot of things during this week.
Including
some minor updates to the console in
the Sagemaker studio.
So what you see right now
was true until two days ago,
but because we have to prepare the slides ahead of time,
we haven't had the time to update it yet to the
new video.
However, the concept that I wanna, whether
I'm gonna walk you through and talk you through,
are actually gonna be exactly the same,
regardless of what the UI looks like,
right? So let's get started doing a
prefer direct preference optimization with SageMaker AI
on Nova models.
So, how does that work? So, you jump into Sage
Maker Studio,
you have a use case that you wanna solve, you already
have in your brain, what is your use case.
So you need to figure out where to start.
Starting point is always the jumpstart
hub in this case, because Nova is available
as part of the jumpstart model hub. Now it's
called just models.
You select the model that you wanna use.
Sam was talking about Nova Micro before,
but now you can use Nova 2.0 Lite, etc.
etc. And then select
the train button all the way
up top,
which effectively allows you to choose the
right training option.
I think this got stuck somehow, so.
Let me
Let me start that again real quick.
The good thing about live demos, even the recording
sometimes can break, all right?
PowerPoint is not always our friend.
But you know,
let's recap. Let's go to the jumpstart.
Let's choose the right model from the model hub.
There's many models out there. We're focusing on
Nova right now, but there's also Lama model,
Queen model, Mistral model, really,
uh,
you, it's just a matter of choice. Choose the right one for your
use case.
Some of them will be trainable, so you can select
train all the way up top.
And then you get to choose the right techniques
that you want,
whether it's supervised fine tuning, whether it's direct
preference optimization. It tells you which
compute, it tells you what format
of data do you need,
so make sure that you have data in the right
format before starting your
job. It shows you the code
for the notebook itself, so you don't have to
do anything through the UI if you don't want
to. You are provided with the code.
In this example, I'll walk through the recipe
using the recipe in StageMaker Hyperpot,
but you can also use the training jobs.
Make sure you have a training cluster available,
so a hyperpod cluster available.
In this case, it is a restricted instance group
cluster type inage maker, Hyperpod,
and then all you have to do is just select
that cluster and click the notebook
to click the button to open
the notebook in the right, uh, Jupiter lab
space running
on top of the Hyperpod cluster.
Of course, these notebooks are publicly available. They
are available in the Gitup repository. So, if
you don't wanna go through having a hyperpod cluster,
you can just pull the notebook directly from the web.
The Notebook contains a bunch of information, contains
the usual prerequisites, the usual installation,
running the different code. It shows you what
is the code to actually run
the start the training job, and you will see that
we pointed to the recipes,
and once you start the actual
training job from the Hyperpod cluster,
all the information will be available
in the available tasks in
Sage Baker Hyperpod.
So, if we go back to the end
to end path for
model customization and for creating agents,
now we've gone through customization,
but the next step is evaluating the model.
So how do you go about evaluating
an LLM?
There's different techniques, there are different metrics,
and we're, there is no
silver bullet
to correct to correctly perform evaluation.
You will have different techniques. You will have general metrics.
You can use, for example, perplexity or accuracy
to to statistically evaluate
the quality of the model,
but you can also go a little bit deeper and
for example,
consider
tasks specific metrics. This is very
relevant, especially in the world of agents,
where you wanna make sure that the agent actually follows,
for example, the trajectory.
Of solving the problem in the right way.
Although the results might be the same,
a model or an agent can take
10 steps,
whereas another one can take 2 steps.
So it could be a number of steps, it
could be the quality of the steps that are being executed
in between.
Of course, we can't forget about hallucinations,
bias and toxic toxicity metrics.
So all of those kind of metrics, they
need to be taken into account for evaluating
the model the right way.
So how can you perform evaluation of a model?
Classically, you would go with a rule-based heuristics.
For example, this is great if you all
you care about is using publicly
available or commonly known metrics
like F1, Rouge, uh,
or any other kind of
uh well-known metrics. A real good
example is also if you're solving a problem
which could be, for example, SQL query
generation, could be execution of the
SQL query.
Does the SQL query actually execute once you've
generated it?
Does the result that come out of the SQL query,
is it actually correct or is it wrong?
So those kind of rule-based, they can be leveraged
and used to improve
the model training itself.
I'm thinking about techniques like RLVR,
so reinforcement learning with verifiable rewards.
You execute a query in that case, you get the result.
Is the result correct? Let's give a reward
to the model training.
If it's not correct, then just give a negative
reward. However,
some use cases, they do not necessarily
have a way
to correctly define heuristics or rules
to evaluate
the model.
Which is why we go for LLM as a judge
or LLM based critique.
It's a really flexible technique and a really customizable
technique, because it allows you to define
a specific prompt.
Which can evaluate through a
bigger model, a teacher model if you wanna call it that way, or
rather a judge model as we
should call it.
It allows you to evaluate
a textual output from another
model. So, let's think for example that
as Sam was saying before, we have Nova Premiere,
that's a great model, it's a very big model,
performing super well on a range of use cases,
but we wanna make sure that Nova Micro
can solve the use cases I want.
So what I can do is that I can fine tune,
as I was showing before, Nova Micro,
and then leverage, for example, Nova Premiere
to evaluate the output and the inferences
of Nova Micro after fine tuning,
to make sure that I can compare, for example, the base
performance to the fine-tuned performance.
Is the outcome better? In what
measure is it better?
For example, if we go back to the SQL query
use case,
semantic correctness is not something that
you can actually compute in terms of a number.
Someone has to look at the semantics of your SQL
query and say,
does writing the SQL query in that way
actually equates to running
a the writing it in this other
way. And LLMs are great at
doing those kind of uh tasks.
If you wanna know more about different metrics
for uh evaluation using LLM as a judge,
there's a whole list of some examples,
but once again, what I usually suggest is that
evaluate and possibly
create
the metric that makes the most sense for your
use case.
In my case was the semantic correctness
or semantic equivalence. In your case, it
might be something completely different.
So, now you've fine tuned your model
using Hyperpod, or Sagemaker training
jobs,
you've evaluated the performances of your model.
So what do you do after that?
The next step is to take that model
and make sure it's available for queries and for inferences.
Now, you can take a Nova model and deploy
it on a a Bedrock inference using custom
model import.
You can use either on-demand provisioning
of that model, which means it's there, it
will be offline until you actually call it. It will take a
second to spin up, and then it's available
for inferences as much as you want.
And this is available for techniques such as
theft, DPO, direct preference optimization,
and distillation.
Or it's available through provision throughput, which
means it's always available, always there,
just call it and it's available for you to run a query,
but it's available for all techniques.
On the other side, you can also take that
model and deploy it on Sagemaker.
Whether it's on a real-time inference endpoint,
which is effectively a
virtual machine, an instance
that we run for you managed by the SageMaker
control plane.
We load it with the image, we load it with a with
a with a model image,
and it's available for you to run queries 24/7
as much as you want.
Or you can also use HyperPod. We recently
introduced the capability of running inference
endpoints in HyperPod,
so that you can either choose to pay by the minute
that you're running the inference endpoint
or just have it available in a highly scalable
cluster.
Just a note,
it's currently not possible for Amazon Nova models
to be deployed on Sage Maker, neither endpoints
or Hyperpod,
but You know,
just wait for it, all right? I'm afraid I
can't say anything more.
Let's take a look at what evaluation and deployment
look like.
So after I've trained my model, what I
can do is that I can select,
evaluate all the way up top.
And there would be also evaluation recipes, which
are also available in GitHub.
Just like before, you can select which recipe
you wanna do,
generic text benchmark,
bring your own data set for uh
question and answering, or LLM is a judge recipe.
This example will do question answer. You
always have the button that says view the format,
and once again, if you use Hyperpot, it's as
simple as Hyperpot start job
and provide the path to the recipe.
Once again,
this will become a task in your Hyperport
cluster management.
So if you have Hyperport task manager, you will
see everything,
and you will be able to
output the evaluation metrics and
consume them as you prefer in a streamlet
app or directly on a in a notebook.
Then you can take the model and deploy it to
Bedrock for inference. It's literally
two calls.
Create a custom model import
or create provision model throughput.
That's all you need to do, and then you can ask a
question. What is the weather in Rome, Italy Italy?
Of course, make sure you provide a tool to your
agent, otherwise, how does he know what the weather
looks like in Rome at this point?
And if you can tell, yes, I am Italian as well, so
this is why the demo talks about Rome, Italy.
I'm not from Rome, but it's a beautiful city. If you
haven't been, please
go. Awesome.
So we have customized the model,
we evaluated its performances. We have deployed
the model to production with an endpoint or
in this case with Bedrock CMI.
How do we go to production? So how do we actually
build an agent? Who has already
built an agent here in this room?
OK, OK, good. I see a lot of people building
agents.
And you might have used one of these,
uh, open source frameworks, right?
Our heart goes with Stras agents
because it's one of the opinionated ways that we have
for building agents in a simple way
with AWS technologies and not
necessarily only AWS technologies.
You're gonna see that Stras agents is a framework that allows
you to connect to
Olama, OpenAI,
Gemini,
anthropic, really connect to whatever kind
of model provider you want.
We think it's the easiest way to build agents,
but we know you have your opinionated view.
So if you wanna use Lagraph,
land chain, OpenAI agents SDK,
Crew AI, Google ADK,
Lama Index, and probably so many more out there that I
don't even know they exist.
Most of the frameworks out there are compatible
with Bedrock custom model inference. They're compatible
with SageMaker endpoints to generate
inferences.
And once you have built your agents, you have written
the code to create your agent,
then the very next step is to
get that, that agent into production.
We have created an end to end managed
platform for agent deployment
and management and running those agents,
which is called Amazon Bedrock Agent Corp.
If you haven't been to an agent core specific session,
I highly suggest you guys
take the time between today and tomorrow to
go to an agent core session.
I believe it's a very interesting service that you should
definitely check out.
Also, because it comes with many different sub-services
which solve different problems
in the what we call this production
chasm.
So, what do you need to get an agent
from development, all the way down to
production, ranging from where do you
run the model,
the agent, sorry.
If it has a memory or not,
please use memory with your agents.
Identity. How does it have the permission to
access the different resources?
How does it connect to the available APIs
that you have in your enterprise?
How can you use, for example, tools like code
interpreter or browser
to effectively run code or connect
to the web?
And then finally,
arguably the most important,
how do you understand how your agent is running
in terms of observability.
I've spoken enough
already. We've seen 2 demos,
we've covered the agent capabilities, we've covered
how to customize the model, so let's wrap up
things a little bit.
When you go back home after this, of
course, enjoy the replay tonight first, then
go home. What you will
need to do in order to solve your genic
AI use case.
You will likely need to, first of all,
take a stab at the already available models.
There are many different good models out there.
Sam walked us through techniques like
context engineering,
rag,
prompt engineering, that can help you solve already
your problem as is.
If your problem is a really custom one,
then you might want to evaluate
model customization.
In a simpler way, you can do it through
Bedrock is really easy to
get started.
If you wanna have a little bit more control,
then you can use the techniques available in SageMaker
to customize your model.
Then always, always evaluate
the performances of the model after you fine-tuned
it. Cause you wanna understand if
it's actually performing better than the base
model,
or you might wanna go through additional techniques.
Then that model needs to be available for queries,
so we deploy it either with Bedrock CMI
or
on a Sage maker inference, whether it's an
endpoint or hyperpod.
And then finally,
write the code for your agent in the lang
in the open source framework that you prefer.
Once again, shout out to Strand's agents for that,
and then take that to production using
a tool like Amazon Sage Maker, Amazon Bedrock
Agent core.
When do you need to customize? It's a
very valid and interesting
question to ask yourself at the very beginning.
Once again, for me, the easiest way is just
test the base model as is and
decide on there if you need
more performance,
if you need to be more aligned to your business, if
you need to be more cost effective. We've
seen a lot of customers move.
To smaller language models rather than using
large language models because they are much
more cost effective,
they can be customized and they can solve one task
really well at a fraction of the cost of a larger
model. But it could also
be a technical question.
Maybe you have already the training data,
which makes it super easy to customize a model,
or you have a team with a technical expertise,
and that team can then act effectively
as a reinforcement algorithm
for the model fine-tune.
To recap the techniques that are available for fine tuning,
Bedrock supports theft and installation.
SageMaker supports a whole range of different
techniques,
so you can go ahead and choose the one that makes the most sense
for you.
And one thing that I want you to take away from this
is that
do not just settle on one fine tuning
techniques.
Fine tuning is a spectrum. It
goes from just prompt engineering
all the way down to continued pre-training,
per per.
Theft, full rank and all the other
different techniques,
direct preference optimization, etc. etc.
So really evaluate
how much time and effort
you wanna put in the model customization process,
how much complicated you want this
process to be, and what kind of outcome
you expect from the different techniques.
And of course, remember that if you wanna learn more
about Amazonova, but in general about
AWS technologies,
we do have the skill builder portal. It's
a great way for you to get more hands-on.
First of all, you have to go through the documentation, etc. etc.
but if you wanna be a little bit more hands-on and learn more
about the specificity of some of the techniques,
you can go ahead and jump into the skill builder
process where you have all the trainings available
for Nova, as well as for a bunch of other techniques.
With that said, I wanna thank you. Thank you
for listening to us for, uh, all this time,
uh, and if you have any questions, we're gonna be
just here, uh, next to the
room. Uh, feel free to come and ask any
question and please, as you leave,
remember, if you take a second
to go to the app and
fill in the survey, we say the feedback is a
gift. It's always nice if you can tell us,
hey, Sam and David, they were two great presenters,
so we're looking forward to their next session.
Thank you very much.